I'm sending you some snapshots of Korea...
...with its four distinct seasons.
Tradition meets modernity...
...in the heart of one of the world's biggest cities.
All this beauty and excitement can be found here in Korea.
We would like to share these marvels with you.
This is why we look forward to you visiting Korea.
I'm thinking of you today,...
...as I often do these days.
I'm glad that we are friends.
We are your friends.
We share dreams and happiness.
We are sharing our unique writing system, Hangul, invented in 1443.
It's one of the world's most scientific alphabets.
We are learning and preparing many things...
...for our time together is precious.
You and I, we are friends.
We're closer than ever before.
I am your friend and you are mine.
We are friends.